Dans le mot convaincre il y a "con"!
Et puis il y a aussi "vaincre".
Je ne sais pas, je trouve que ça résume
assez bien une bonne partie des débats
qu'on peut lire ou avoir sur internet
et l'état d'esprit des participants.
En gros on est là pour vaincre
et de toute façon les autres sont des cons.
Je sais de quoi je parle, je le fais aussi.
Mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on est aussi mauvais
quand il s'agit de confronter nos idées,
de débattre que ce soit des forums,
des réseaux sociaux,
je ne parle même pas de twitter.
L'immense majorité du temps,
quand on essaye d'avoir un débat,
les échanges ne sont quand même pas
hyper constructifs,
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Et finalement ce n'est pas forcément
le débat le problème,
en fait même quand on est tout seul, qu'on
débat avec nous-mêmes en quelque sorte,
on est assez mauvais à évaluer correctement
des arguments, à résonner,
à se former une opinion éclairée,
surtout quand on touche à des sujets chauds,
ayant une portée politique.
Alors oui bien sûr on s'imagine tous
qu'on est objectif, rigoureux,
honnête intellectuellement,
mais est-ce que c'est vraiment le cas?
Est-ce qu'on ne se fait pas des illusions
en croyant être capable de raisonner
avec rigueur et objectivité?
Toutes ces questions, c'est le thème
d'un livre que je viens de lire:
"The Scout Mindset" de Julia Galef.
Et j'ai trouvé ça suffisamment stimulant
pour décider de vous en parler.
Alors Julia Galef, qui est
une podcasteuse américaine,
s'est spécialisée dans ce qu'on pourrait
appeler "la rationalité appliquée",
c'est-à-dire: comment faire en sorte
de mieux raisonner, d'être plus rationnel,
quand on essaye de se faire une opinion
ou bien d'en débattre avec d'autres?
Alors cette question est assez classique,
j'imagine qu'il y a déjà
des kilomètres de livres
qui ont été écrits sur le sujet,
mais j'ai trouvé son approche
vraiment intéressante car très pragmatique.
Plutôt que des injonctions abstraites
ou bien des considérations théoriques,
Julia Galef nous présente
des petits trucs concrets,
qui je pense, peuvent nous aider
à mieux raisonner.
En tout cas moi, j'ai l'impression
que ça va m'aider.
Alors ça vaut le coup
que je le partage avec vous non?
[Jingle]
Le livre de Julia Galef est construit
autour d'une métaphore:
celle de l'éclaireur ("scout" en anglais) .
Alors pour visualiser la métaphore
imaginez une armée en campagne,
avec des soldats sur un champ de bataille.
Beaucoup de ces soldats vont avoir pour
mission de défendre une position,
ou d'attaquer une position ennemie.
À la base, ils ne sont pas là pour
remettre en question l'objectif donné,
mais pour assurer le combat.
Et puis dans l'armée
vous avez aussi les éclaireurs,
et leur rôle 1er ça n'est pas
de combattre l'ennemi,
mais d'aller sur le terrain pour essayer
d'en apprendre un maximum.
Ils vont chercher par exemple à dresser
une carte des lieux,
la rivière passe ici, il y a un pont là,
le pont est en bon état etc.
Le job des éclaireurs c'est d'essayer
de voir les choses telles qu'elles sont
et de les rapporter de la façon
la plus fidèle possible.
Et ce que nous dit Julia Galef,
c'est que quand on se retrouve
en situation de questionner nos opinions,
soit tout seul, soit en débattant,
eh bien on se comporte souvent
comme des soldats.
On a nos idées, nos convictions
et puis on va spontanément rejeter
tout ce qui ne colle pas
avec l'opinion qu'on a déjà.
Dans un débat on va avant tout chercher
à convaincre l'autre,
et on est surtout pas là
pour changer d'avis hein.
Et c'est souvent à ça
que ressemble les débats,
que ce soit en ligne ou même en famille.
Avec sa métaphore Julia Galef
nous invite à nous comporter
moins comme des soldats,
et plus comme des éclaireurs.
Et "penser en éclaireur" ça veut dire:
essayer au maximum de voir les choses
telles qu'elles sont,
et tenter d'établir une carte
la plus véridique possible de la situation,
en faisant abstraction
de nos idées préconçues.
Ce qui fait qu'on est bien plus souvent
des soldats que des éclaireurs,
c'est ce phénomène connu
sous le terme de "raisonnement motivé".
Le raisonnement motivé c'est le fait que
quand on a une idée plus ou moins ancrée,
consciemment ou pas, on va souvent
tout faire pour s'y accrocher.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne va pas vraiment
écouter les choses qui vont à l'encontre,
on va sélectionner uniquement
les arguments et les preuves
qui vont dans notre sens.
Et puis on va juste renforcer
nos convictions et défendre
notre position comme un bon soldat.
On fait tous du raisonnement motivé,
moi, vous, personne n'est immunisé,
et il faut bien voir que si
le raisonnement motivé existe,
c'est pour plein de bonnes raisons.
C'est quand même plus confortable
de ne pas remettre en question nos opinions,
ça nous fait nous sentir bien,
ça nous donne souvent un sentiment
de supériorité intellectuelle ou morale
et puis aussi d'appartenance
à un groupe qui partage nos idées.
Nos opinions sont souvent profondément
liées à notre identité,
que ce soit l'identité religieuse,
professionnelle ou politique
et donc on n'a pas franchement envie
de remettre ça en question,
c'est pas très agréable, d'où le fait
de se comporter comme des soldats.
Et donc Julia Galef nous dit:
"soyons plutôt comme des éclaireurs",
ou du moins essayons de l'être
un peu plus souvent.
Personne n'est parfait mais essayons
de progresser dans cette direction.
Honnêtement bon,
la métaphore soldats/éclaireur
c'est sympa mais elle a ses limites.
En fait pour moi c'est pas vraiment
le point central du livre,
c'est juste un moyen
d'avoir un titre accrocheur.
Parce qu'en soi l'idée n'est pas
spécialement nouvelle.
Oui bien sûr, plein de gens
depuis longtemps ont expliqué
qu'il fallait être objectif,
examiner les données sans à priori,
chercher absolument tout ce qui pourrait
aller à l'encontre de notre croyance,
être pleinement ouvert
aux arguments des autres,
être honnête intellectuellement quoi!
Oui sauf qu'en pratique,
ben ça marche pas vraiment.
Tout le monde s'imagine
être objectif et honnête
et tout le monde s'imagine
que ce sont surtout les autres
qui ont besoin de l'être plus.
Et puis au total on n'avance pas beaucoup.
Et en fait ce que j'ai aimé
dans le livre de Julia Galef,
c'est que plutôt que de s'en tenir
à des grands principes généraux
pour atteindre la vertu
dans la rationalité,
elle nous donne des pistes
concrètes assez pratiques,
pour essayer de s'améliorer un peu.
Et je vais vous en partager quelques-unes.
Une des premières pistes
c'est d'essayer de dédramatiser
le changement d'opinion.
C'est particulièrement vrai
dans un débat public ou pire en ligne:
le fait de changer d'opinion
est vu comme une défaite,
comme la reconnaissance d'une erreur,
d'une faute quoi, une espèce d'humiliation.
Et donc changer d'opinion
c'est un peu s’ auto-flageller.
Mais ça c'est l'état d'esprit du soldat,
alors qu'un éclaireur lui,
si il voit que le pont
n'est pas là où il pensait,
eh ben il met à jour sa carte
et puis c'est tout quoi!
Ce que vous recommande Julia Galef,
c'est de considérer nos opinions,
notre vision du monde,
plus comme une carte vivante et dynamique
que l'on peut ajuster petit à petit,
sans que ce soit un drame.
Voyez les changements d'opinion
comme des mises à jour de votre carte,
pas comme des défaites sur le terrain.
Alors oui, c'est souvent un problème
lors des débats en ligne,
où, dès que vous écrivez un truc,
c'est considéré comme votre opinion,
irrévocable, éternelle et absolue.
Et là-dessus Julia Galef
cite un chouette exemple.
C'est le blog de la développeuse Devon Zuegel
qui invite dans sa description,
à voir ces posts non pas, je cite:
"comme une opinion statique,
mais comme un flux de pensées attrapées
en plein milieu de leur mise à jour".
Je trouve ça super comme formulation,
j'ai bien envie de lui piquer la formule
et de l'écrire aussi sur mon blog.
Et je crois que si j'étais sûr que les gens
voyaient mes écrits comme ça,
j'écrirais plus souvent pour partager ce
que j'ai dans la tête.
Dans un autre genre: dans une interview
le philosophe Michel Foucault
le présentait autrement, il disait:
J'aime bien aussi.
Une autre façon concrète de dédramatiser
le changement d'opinion,
c'est d'essayer d'y prendre plaisir
ou du moins de ne pas le voir
comme un truc "inconfortable".
Vous croyez en quelque chose,
on vous présente un argument
qui va à l'encontre: super!
"Embrasser la confusion"
nous dit Julia Galef, vous savez
c'est un peu la citation attribuée
à l'écrivain Isaac Asimov:
"La phrase la plus intéressante en
science, ça n'est pas "Euréka! "
mais c'est: tiens, c'est bizarre! ".
Ben voilà, essayons de trouver du plaisir
dans notre propre confusion.
Julia Galef nous dit que c'est
comme de l'exercice physique,
parfois ça nous rend courbaturés,
mais bon à la fin on se sent bien.
Et voir son opinion vaciller
en face de contre arguments c'est pareil.
Essayez de valoriser ce sentiment.
Je sais pas moi, décernez-vous des "like"
mentaux quand ça se produit dans votre tête.
Ah oui, je parle bien de vous,
avec mon histoire de like hein.
Valoriser le changement d'opinion,
c'est un truc interne,
c'est pas juste aller faire semblant
de féliciter l'adversaire
quand il change enfin d'opinion,
ça c'est bien, mais c'est un peu facile.
Je crois que c'est un truc essentiel
avec la philosophie du livre de Julia Galef.
Tout ce qu'on dit là, c'est pour essayer
de s'améliorer soi même.
C'est pas des outils pour essayer
d'aller critiquer les autres,
ou bien des munitions pour gagner
des débats sur internet.
Une difficulté importante dans la démarche
de dédramatisation du changement d'opinion,
c'est que, comme je le mentionnais
plus tôt, nos opinions
font souvent partie intégrante de notre
identité, et être confus sur un truc
qui touche à notre identité, c'est pas
très agréable, surtout publiquement.
Alors pour se prémunir de ça,
Julia Galef nous invite à nous rappeler
que nos opinions sont contingentes,
c'est à dire qu'elles sont
le produit de notre histoire personnelle,
de nos rencontres,
de notre environnement, du hasard aussi,
et il faut s'imaginer
qu'à pas grand chose près, peut-être
notre opinion sur tel ou tel sujet
aurait pu être différente.
Julia Galef nous dit:
Je ne sais pas comment le traduire
avec finesse, un truc genre:
"porter son identité avec légèreté".
En gros c'est l'idée de voir nos opinions
comme une description de ce qu'on pense
à l'instant T, et pas comme une sorte
d'étendard qu'on arbore fièrement,
genre dans sa bio twitter.
Oui alors du coup là, c'est mal parti!
Bon, une fois qu'on a dédramatisé
le fait de changer d'avis,
on peut passer à la vitesse supérieure
et chercher à se chatouiller un peu
sur nos propres croyances.
Julia Galef nous propose
plusieurs petits tests,
des expériences de pensées
qu'on peut s'amuser à faire.
Un exemple c'est le test de conformité.
Imaginez que vous avez une opinion
sur un sujet x,
et vous aimez beaucoup telle personne…
Une personne publique ou de votre entourage,
qui aussi défend ardemment l'opinion x.
Comment réagiriez-vous si soudainement
elle changeait d'avis?
Alors ça a l'air facile hein,
mais faites vraiment l'exercice, allez-y.
Genre vous êtes fan de Jean-Marc Jancovici
et, si demain il vous dit:
"que tout bien considéré, le nucléaire,
il y a quand même beaucoup trop
d'incertitudes critiques et donc on va
peut-être éviter quoi! "
Ça marche dans les deux sens.
Vous êtes fan de Greenpeace,
et si demain ils déclarent:
"que tout bien considéré, on n'y arrivera pas
sans le développement massif du nucléaire".
Ou bien que penseriez-vous si soudainement
le pape François disait que…?
Ah ben là, en fait il l'a vraiment dit.
Bref ce sont des expériences de pensée,
mais c'est toujours stimulant je trouve.
Une autre expérience de pensée
qui se rapproche de ça,
c'est le test du scepticisme sélectif.
En gros on sait bien que, quand quelqu'un
va nous apporter un argument,
on va juger l'argument d'une façon différente
suivant que ça va dans notre sens ou pas.
Et pour se guérir de ça, une expérience
de pensée facile à faire,
c'est chaque fois qu'on nous
apporte une preuve,
il faut se demander:
"comment je réagirai si cette preuve montrait
le contraire de ce qu'elle montre? "
Alors imaginons: vous trouvez que,
selon une étude américaine,
plus on joue aux jeux vidéo,
plus on est calme, sociable et fort en maths.
Génial! on tweet ça, vite fait
sans même lire l'article,
et puis on tague Nadine Morano
pour faire bonne mesure.
Mais si l'étude avait montré le contraire:
que les jeux vidéo rendent stupide
et violent, alors là ouais, perso
j'aurais été lire en détail l'article,
genre à chercher la petite bête dans l'étude,
déjà qui c'est qu'a publié ça?
Ça a été publié où?
Est-ce que c'est fiable?
Personnellement du fait que,
bon, j'ai un background scientifique
et quelques bases en statistiques,
je pense que je suis particulièrement sujet
à ce phénomène de scepticisme sélectif.
Si une étude va dans mon sens,
souvent je vais lire vaguement
le résumé de l'article et par contre
si ça va à l'encontre de ce que je pense,
je vais décortiquer l'analyse statistique,
regarder les petits p,
les facteurs de confusion,
est ce qu'ils ont bien tout contrôlé?
Est-ce que les hypothèses
des modèles sont bonnes,
combien il y avait de sujets?
Et puis d'abord, il faut répliquer l'étude
il faut faire une méta analyse pour être sûr,
En fait on ne peut rien conclure.
Il faut que j'essaye de me corriger là-dessus,
Je veux dire soit je creuse les articles,
soit je ne les creuse pas,
mais je ne peux pas faire
deux poids deux mesures.
Et Julia Galef nous dit donc
que le meilleur moyen d'éviter le:
"2 poids, 2 mesures", c'est d'imaginer
systématiquement ce qu'on ferait
si les preuves qu'on découvre,
allaient dans l'autre sens.
Ça me semble être une petite expérience
de pensée vraiment très simple,
très concrète et qu'on peut faire
presque plusieurs fois par jour.
Julia Galef nous parle aussi
du test de Turing idéologique,
un concept inventé
par l'économiste Bryan Caplan.
Vous connaissez le test de Turing
en intelligence artificielle,
c'est l'idée que l'on aura vraiment une IA
le jour où, de façon convaincante,
un algorithme pourra se faire
passer pour un humain,
dans une conversation sous forme de chat.
Eh bien le test de Turing idéologique,
c'est d'essayer d'exposer
la position opposée à la vôtre
d'une façon que quelqu'un
qui ne connaît pas votre opinion
pourrait s'y méprendre.
Genre: vous êtes pronucléaire,
eh bien essayez d'écrire un article de blog
qui défende la position des antinucléaires.
Et pas en faisant une caricature,
mais d'une façon convaincante,
telle qu'en lisant votre texte quelqu'un
penserait que vous êtes sincèrement
antinucléaire, et pourrait même
se laisser convaincre par vos arguments.
C'est ça le test de Turing idéologique.
C'est un bon moyen de s'assurer
qu'on fait l'effort de comprendre
la position des autres.
Si vous avez des enfants qui vous posent
des questions sur des sujets piquants,
ça peut être un bon exercice
d'essayer de leur présenter les alternatives,
en essayant de masquer votre position réelle.
Genre: papa est-ce que la peine de mort
c'est bien?
Alors…!
Ben moi je trouve ça stimulant en tout cas.
Bien et maintenant troisième étape:
une fois que vous êtes à l'aise
à essayer de chatouiller
vos propres convictions,
essayez sincèrement de vous mettre en danger,
de changer d'avis.
Exposez-vous vraiment à des contre arguments.
Alors avec les réseaux sociaux, on parle
souvent de la notion de bulles de filtres,
vous savez: en gros l'idée
qu'on ne se connecte qu'avec des gens
avec qui on a, grosso modo,
les mêmes opinions,
et donc on se retrouve toujours exposé
au même côté des choses,
les idées tournent en boucle,
et puis on a un effet de chambre d'écho.
Et parfois on entend que pour éviter ça,
il faudrait s'exposer de façon volontaire
à des sources ou des médias
ayant des opinions opposées.
Genre: vous êtes un fidèle lecteur
du "Monde diplomatique",
eh ben, je sais pas moi, faites l'effort
de lire aussi "Valeurs actuelles",
au moins une semaine sur deux.
Ouais, alors non, ce conseil,
ça ne marche pas du tout!
Il y a un effet assez bien documenté
en psychologie sociale,
c'est "l'effet boomerang": si on essaye
de convaincre quelqu'un qu'il se trompe,
eh bien ça ne fait souvent que le renforcer
dans ses propres convictions,
et ça produit donc l'effet inverse
de ce qui était escompté.
Donc si vous êtes un avide lecteur
de "Valeurs actuelles", ça ne sert à rien
de vous abonner en plus au
au "Monde diplomatique" et à "l'Humanité",
ça ne fera que vous polariser
encore plus dans la même direction.
Julia Galef nous dit que, dans le fond,
tout ça c'est un peu logique,
un média avec une ligne éditoriale
politique forte,
va forcément écrire des choses
pour flatter et plaire à son audience.
Ce qui ne correspond pas forcément
aux arguments qu'il faudrait donner
au camp adverse pour essayer
d'avoir un débat constructif.
Et donc Julia Galef nous dit:
n'écoutez pas des gens qui
vont vous polariser,
mais plutôt des gens qui,
par leur façon de faire,
vont vous faciliter le fait
de vous ouvrir à leurs arguments.
Donc plutôt que de vous abonner
à des journaux dont les points de vue
sont complètement opposés aux vôtres,
essayez plutôt d'identifier
1 ou 2 personnes pour qui
vous avez de l'estime,
que vous trouvez raisonnables,
et qui peuvent vous exposer intelligemment
des arguments différents des vôtres.
Ça peut être quelqu'un de proche,
famille ou amis, mais ça peut être aussi
un blogueur, un éditorialiste de presse
ou de radio dont vous appréciez
l'argumentation sans forcément
être d'accord systématiquement.
Alors par contre pas sur Twitter, non!
N'oubliez pas que, se laisser convaincre,
ça demande du temps.
Julia Galef nous le rappelle:
un argument exposé en 30 secondes
ou 280 caractères, ça sera inévitablement
une version simpliste.
Donc ça ne marchera pas,
n'essayez pas comme ça!
Julia Galef résume tout ça en disant:
donnons-nous les meilleures chances possibles
de pouvoir changer d'avis.
Honnêtement, c'est pas facile hein,
mais bon, essayons quand même!
[Jingle]
Oui, alors tout ça, c'est bien gentil, ces
histoires de changer d'avis tout le temps,
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
de nos convictions profondes?
Si on est tout le temps à douter,
à essayer de les remettre en question,
comment peut-on lutter pour une cause?
Mine de rien il y a quand même
tout un tas de grands progrès
dans l'Histoire et la société
qui ont été acquis
par l'activisme et le militantisme dédié
de gens qui croyaient fort à leurs idées,
si on remet sans cesse en question
nos croyances plutôt que de nous battre,
comment on fait pour avancer?
Eh bien ce que Julia Galef nous dit, c'est
que ce n'est pas forcément incompatible,
et elle propose le concept
"d'activisme efficace".
Son idée c'est que les actions
militantes en général,
peuvent avoir différentes motivations
et différents effets,
parfois certains actes ont un impact concret
et font progresser la cause
d'une façon mesurable, et puis parfois
certains actes sont plus des marqueurs
d'identité qui nous font plaisir à nous,
qui nous permettent de nous affirmer
vis-à-vis des autres et de notre groupe,
mais qui n'ont pas forcément
un effet concret sur la situation du monde.
Quand Julia Galef nous invite
à porter notre identité avec légèreté,
son idée est d'essayer de nous faire
privilégier les actions à fort impact,
par rapport aux actions ayant seulement
pour but d'affirmer notre identité
et c'est parfois décorrélé
voire contradictoire.
Plus vous portez votre identité en étendard,
moins vous vous donnez de chances
de vraiment convaincre les autres.
C'est le problème d'adopter un ton
un peu moralisateur, je cite Julia Galef:
il est difficile de convaincre une personne
quand vous vous sentez moralement
et intellectuellement supérieur à elle.
Julia Galef cite aussi la journaliste
et blogueuse Megan McArdle,
qui nous donne une astuce pour repérer
ces situations, elle dit:
"plus votre message vous fait vous sentir
bien à propos de vous-même,
moins il y a de chances qu'il fasse
changer d'avis qui que ce soit".
Donc un tweet du genre "ouais les antivax,
c'est vraiment des gros connards",
c'est peut-être un cri de ralliement
avec des gens dont vous vous sentez proches,
et je veux bien croire
que ça fasse du bien à l'intérieur,
d'écrire un truc pareil, mais ça ne va pas
faire changer d'avis le moindre antivax.
Et des trucs comme ça je pense
que j'en ai fait un certain nombre
et j'espère que c'est plus le cas maintenant
ou que ça l'est moins en tout cas.
L'activisme efficace selon Julia Galef
c'est donc essayer de porter son identité
avec légèreté et de se concentrer
sur les actions ayant potentiellement
un impact fort même si elles
sont moins identitaires.
Elle donne plusieurs exemples
intéressants issus de la lutte
pour la défense des animaux ou encore
l'activisme contre le sida,
où des groupes ont su utiliser
le raisonnement pour troquer des actions
surtout identitaires pour des actions
ayant un impact réel sur leurs causes.
Si j'essayais de présenter ces exemples,
je le ferais sûrement moins bien qu'elle,
alors je vous renvoie au bouquin
si ça vous intéresse.
Pour finir le livre, Julia Galef conclut
en nous disant que si on tient tant que ça
à exposer publiquement
une identité tranchée,
alors autant que ce soit
l'identité de l'éclaireur,
c'est-à-dire l'identité de celui ou celle
qui est fier de mettre à jour ses opinions,
de noter mentalement quand il tombe
dans un raisonnement motivé.
L'éclaireur qui apprécie la confusion
que lui procure un argument qui fait douter,
comme quand on apprécie d'être courbaturé
après une bonne séance d'exercices physiques.
En conclusion, pour ma part
comme je vous l'ai dit,
j'ai trouvé que la métaphore de l'éclaireur
était surtout un moyen sympa
d'illustrer les points.
Ce que j'ai surtout apprécié,
ce sont les conseils concrets,
j'ai l'impression d'avoir réussi
à commencer à les appliquer,
et je vais essayer
de le faire de plus en plus.
Et pour ça je voudrais terminer
par un petit coup de projecteur
pour un service que j'ai découvert
il y a peu de temps et qui je crois,
va pas mal m'aider dans cette direction.
Dans cette vidéo j'ai beaucoup râlé
au sujet de Twitter et sincèrement,
il me semble que Twitter,
dans ce qu'il est devenu aujourd'hui,
incarne vraiment tout ce qui ne va pas.
Je l'utilisais initialement
comme un moyen de faire de la veille
et de partager mes réflexions,
mais j'en ai été dégoûté,
j'ai décidé de ne presque plus y aller,
de ne plus écrire et de me concentrer
sur mon blog et mes vidéos.
Et pour faire ma veille,
j'utilise depuis quelques semaines
un service super qui s'appelle "Flus".
Alors Flus est géré par une seule personne
qui, en plus met la transparence
et la solidarité au centre de son activité,
d'ailleurs le logiciel derrière est libre,
et je précise que je n'ai pas
été payé pour en parler.
Flus permet de rassembler
en un seul endroit deux choses:
les flux d'articles en provenance
de diverses sources comme des blogs,
ce que faisait Googlereader dans le temps,
mais aussi en même temps,
les liens qu'on va bookmarquer à droite,
à gauche pour les lire plus tard.
Et ces deux rôles sont synthétisés
dans une fonctionnalité super
qui s'appelle "le journal",
qui n'est pas un long fil infini de contenu,
mais un espace que l'on décide
volontairement de remplir automatiquement
avec quelques articles en provenance
de nos sources ou de la liste de liens
qu'on a mis de côté.
L'ensemble vraiment super agréable,
donne une sensation de maîtriser
les informations auxquelles on est exposé
et de pouvoir vraiment prendre le temps
de lire de façon intelligente.
Et pour moi ça a complètement remplacé
le fait de scroller Twitter,
Donc allez voir "Flus.fr".
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
j'espère que ce résumé du livre
de Julia Galef vous aura donné envie,
soit de le lire, soit du moins d'essayer
d'améliorer la façon que vous avez
de former vos opinions sur le monde.
Vous pouvez aussi aller voir
la vidéo de "science for all"
qui expose d'autres aspects du livre.
Abonnez-vous, mettez la cloche,
moi sur Facebook ou Twitter… ben non,
Abonnez-vous à "Science étonnante… "
dans "Flus.fr"!
On se retrouve vite pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt.
[Musique]
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -